welcome everybody to the h3 podcast i
am of course your host the fresh prince
of dead air
this episode by the way is brought to
you by ring
i have a 5.45 on wiki feet
unlike our guest here who danny gonzalez
who has a very
sad 3.5 your thoughts danny
is that true
i look it up now before every guest
comes on wikifeet
danny gonzalez which i you know what i
don't know how these people judge
because i think your feet look totally
fine just to be honest with you
okay well that's very interesting
because i had i tweeted about it it was
a bit of a controversy because
i found my wiki feed profile like a
couple months ago
and i had a really low rating so i was
complaining about it and then i think
people went in and rated me higher so i
thought my score would be higher
it is i i stand corrected it's 4.39
okay yeah so that's a definitely
respectable score
yeah the a lot of the pictures if it's
the same ones that i
saw my foot is like swollen all right
yeah yeah my foot there left i can't
well yeah sure i mean yeah that that's
not a night what happened yeah what
happened to your foot
i had like this like autoimmune thing it
was like arthritis basically in my ankle
oh no well yeah did you hear it
yeah it's good now it was like a
temporary thing it was very weird
it happened like right when i got
married
um so most of those pictures are me on
my honeymoon
oh no urgent care in hawaii
because my foot was swollen yeah that's
not that's got to be a little
was it just swelling up out of nowhere
and you're like why is my foot huge
yeah it was like a couple different
joints on my body
um we tried to go to like urgent care
and they like had no idea what was going
on they were like were you in a car
accident recently
um but yeah it eventually went away it
was like
six months and then it went away god
bless i'm so glad that you that
your foot is back to normal
congratulations on 4 trillion
subscribers would you recently hit thank
you man
yeah uh it's a big deal 4 trillion
every single person on earth subscribed
a hundred times yeah yeah actually yeah
you hit four million
subs recently your channel is is uh on
the rise for sure and um
i'm so happy that you're here with us so
yeah i'm excited too
my head you guys love your podcast oh
thank you dude
i love when people say that you know my
face
i am wearing hair gel and i i just
started this
what do you mean wearing is that what
you would say what what would you say
i don't know but wearing it i think i
feel like wearing works
yeah maybe it's weird for me because
does your wife correct you on everything
well i'm just yeah i guess um i'm just
kidding
um i wouldn't know how else to say it i
have hair gel
i have i have hair gel on my head yeah
exactly
that doesn't sound good okay no but fair
enough i think that's a
brilliant object of great observation
but the thing is here that
it's going down on my forehead
and my forehead is super sticky
paper towel deal is so you know how like
you've seen like rudy giuliani or just
like really fat just
people in hot weather and they're always
like
that is me but today i'm in ac and i'm
doing it so that's why
you know is it because you're sweating
and the the hair gel is like melting or
whatever and coming down your forehead
with probably
yeah i think i i just showered so it's
just a whole
loopy uh it's a whole luby moist
which is what i believe elo prefers to
call it
yeah you shouldn't say i'm wearing hair
gel you should say i'm wearing a lubey
moist
yeah yeah that would make more sense to
me what do you do with your hair you put
product in there
yeah um i just get like i don't know if
it's called like a pomade or whatever
but it's just basically just like a gel
or like a wax or something like a
target yeah get on that wax game dude
yeah i don't really know what the
difference between a gel because when i
think of gel i think of like it comes
out of like a
pump bottle like this and you know
but i go for more of like a matte finish
i feel like pomades can be more like
less shiny yeah i think the gel i've got
my hair is just
it kind of just looks wet like your hair
doesn't look wet but your hair is curly
or
i think you maybe need you think i have
to go versus
i need a stronger weapon yeah
well i think it can also depend on when
you apply it
because i have found before that if i
get out of the shower and my hair is not
all the way dry and i put stuff in my
hair then even when my hair does dry for
some reason the product stays like
shiny looking so you might need your
hair to be drier first
yeah i'm kind of new to the whole hair
product thing so i'm learning
i'm learning uh listen
we call you call your fan base greg okay
first of all tell me
why are they why are we called greg
um the origins are from a video that i
made
in like 2017 about jake paul he made a
song about the jake paulers oh yeah
yeah right and so i was goofing on that
and i was like i need a name for my fan
base and i was trying to come up with
something that was like because
jake paul and logan paul both had like a
pun
on their name well logan's was low gang
that's kind of a pun and then jake
paulers he just put er
yeah which is not which is not as good
um i don't know if that's considered a
pun or just like adding energy yeah
so i was like well i got to come up with
something with danny gonzalez but then i
couldn't
that's hard yeah yeah so well actually
no i did call my fans goons for a while
like goon gonzales but that's like
[Music]
yeah um so then i was like well if i
can't figure one out with my name i'll
just pick a different name so i just
decided to call them greg but not the
gragers or the grey gang
just greg i feel like greg is enough
plus i felt like it was funny to start
every video
like i was like specifically talking to
one person
just being like what's up greg at the
beginning of a video yeah
because you know there's some dude named
greg that's like oh [ __ ]
yeah that's me because i don't know if
you've ever watched um
the vlog brothers like uh tom and hank
green
yeah i know i know of them yeah because
they i think they
start videos where they're yeah they're
like good morning john or whatever it's
friday or whatever so i thought it would
be funny if i just like made up a random
person
and was like hey greg at the beginning
of every video but then never explain
who greg is but then
it turned into this joke where my fans
are greg well we we actually
it's funny we we uh got inspired by the
same person we call our fans eli
kleiners
yeah oh that's right yeah so jake paul
inspires all of us
everything yeah i feel like i owe a big
portion of my career to jake
yeah yeah i mean me too man in a way you
know
he did a lot for a lot of our careers so
was there any runner-up names besides
greg what was the short list
um i think that i just looked at like uh
a list of popular baby names but i feel
like it was like from a long time ago
because i feel like greg is not a
popular baby
so it must have been like from the 50s
or something because i
i don't know anyone my age actually
named greg
but i feel like that's why it works
because if you
knew people named greg that were like
your age i feel like you wouldn't want
to buy a hoodie or something that says
greg on it
right because you'd be worried that like
some kid in your class
like thinks you're wearing a hoodie that
has their name on it
so i have to confront you on something
uh danny you or tweeted
once that someone suggested ethan for
the name of the gang
and you had said that ethan is a weak
name
and your fans deserve better i'm here
yes you did i'll pull you i'll pull the
tweet up right now and so i'm basically
here just to confront you on that
when is this from okay pull up the tweet
guys surely i
surely i didn't know you at the time
because you you embody the name ethan
really well and i think you're a very
strong
individual yeah well explain this now
now you're all nice and happy about
ethan
here it is ethan is a weak name my fans
are the strongest army
out there they deserve a name like greg
when is it from 2017 of almost exactly
three years ago
that's really interesting i mean it's
weird because like there are a lot of
people that i don't like that are named
greg
because there's like jake paul's dad is
named greg also
is he greg craig yeah jp
wait what yeah cause we used to be
coming at you
oh yeah there it is gp oh it's gp you
know he used to live in a van outside
team 10 isn't that [ __ ] crazy
i feel like i saw that in videos before
yeah he seems like he just sort of hangs
out and kind of reaps the benefits of
whatever the paul brothers are up to
it's kind of weird
you know he uh i think he disappeared
though because he was like [ __ ]
like underage girls at team 10 house oh
yeah
didn't like a sex tape of his get leaked
too i don't know if that was actually
but i remember seeing something very
graphic on my twitter page
yes yes so he
he disappeared in his rv it came out but
it was getting weird
yeah yeah they're like dad you gotta go
dude
go money at you that would just be so
weird like i can't imagine
doing like what they do and just having
my dad hanging around all the time like
going on tour
or something and like my dad's on the
bus with me
that would just be so weird no yeah i
remember when they have boxing matches
like gp would come up in their corner
when like
tensions would flare no i i watch i
don't know what your relationship's like
with my dad
but i pretty much just pay him to keep
him away
what my relationship's like with your
dad with your dad oh okay
uh yeah cause that's gonna say the same
thing probably probably the same that i
have
yeah no i mean it's i they're great they
i my parents are very supportive but i
don't know if i just like want him
around all the time like making my
business decisions with me
you seem well adjusted you seem like a
normal dude with like
good parents and stuff is that a good
assessment
yeah that's i'm that's very nice of you
to say but yeah i
uh yeah my parents are pretty normal so
i feel like i gotta
do a good hand do you have any diseases
or anything
well you do have the puffy foot whatever
that was
yeah that was that was a pretty
temporary thing although it's like it
has flared up a little bit since then
but that's like
that's pretty minor in the grand scheme
of things i don't really have any like
long-term chronic illnesses wow
what a what a lucky guy dude i know
i mean what you've got like that acid
reflux thing i've got the gerd i've got
the tourettes i have
ocd i can't sleep before
3 a.m i mean what time do you go to bed
what's that what time do you go to bed
oh man
um i try to be in bed at like 11 30. wow
yeah this guy is way too well adjusted
i'm like
with stuff like that i'm like
disciplined to a fault i feel like
sometimes because i'm like
sometimes not even tired and i'm like i
have to get in bed right now
because anytime you hear like people
like motivational people talk they're
they're always like sleep is the most
important thing
yeah you gotta get eight hours of sleep
so i'm super like
anal about that i'm like i need to be in
bed at 11 30.
no they're right i mean i i agree it's
just i cannot fall asleep at times
before three so i'll just
this is probably the worst thing in my
life right now is that i'll go to bed
at three sometimes even later i'm not
gonna [ __ ] lie sometimes
four and i'll wake up super late in the
day and it's just uh
it's just horrible it's horrible dude
yeah i my sleeping schedule's pretty
good but my eating schedule gets really
weird
like i don't have an eating schedule bro
i [ __ ] just
eat what is the eating schedule
well you have like breakfast lunch and
dinner like most people eat lunch at
like noon
and then dinner at like six i don't know
but sometimes it's usually because of
like i'm working and then i don't eat
lunch until like
four and then i'm like well when am i
supposed to eat dinner now so i end up
eating dinner at like nine
and that feels weird wow so i guess
that's basically the biggest like
problem wow yeah that's a huge
issue dude what does your wife do for a
living
um she's in school right now she's doing
her master's in social work
oh so yeah so she's just doing school
and she has an internship that's where
she is right now
um working with like she's doing like
therapy for
youth and uh yeah
sounds like another well-adjusted nice
person
she's very well adjusted that's my
favorite thing about her
um my favorite video of yours is when
you spent 13 000
on ads promoting your channel and you
gained 40 subscribers
that was [ __ ] awesome yeah that was
pretty epic
um total great great use of money
325 dollars per
subscriber i that makes me wonder about
how someone like tai lopez
i guess he's selling a product and again
and like a whole thing but
i just wonder it just makes me think how
do people make money doing that it's
just
because when i see ads on youtube i
bounce the [ __ ] out immediately
i know yeah that's something i didn't
really think about before i made that
video but it's like i don't think i've
ever clicked on a youtube ad once
ever ever or like even an instagram ad
or anything like that because that's the
reason i made them because of those
instagram game ads
and it's like i don't know i don't know
what kind of person you have to be to
click on them but i don't think i've
ever met anyone like that
so i don't know how they work they're
out there apparently because they're
i mean thank god they're out there
because we're all making money because
of them you know what i mean but damn
yeah that's a good point have any of you
guys ever i mean there's a bunch of
people on the call have any of you guys
ever seen anything
and clicked ever like i sometimes you
see a car commercial and you're like
cool
lincoln i'll never buy lincoln
no but there have been ads that like
i'll watch all the way through because
i'm like oh this is an interesting ad
but then the second it's over i'm like
okay
i forget about it immediately hmm they
got you then
they got you but he made this video
where he was like uh
he's like week one normal dude
week two cool dude week three wizard
trying to get people
to sign up that was the worst performing
one right
yes i think so so i think it was that
one was the worst
and then was the second one then like
the normal one
and then the the one that performed the
best me spanking myself it was something
himself aggressively on a green screen
and that one
so that one did the best yes like oh my
god
the test was like so i i do a series
about like
bad instagram ads and like i'm sure you
guys have seen like bad game ads where
they're just like the weirdest
phrasing and like really graphic stuff
to try to get you to download the game
so i was like i'm gonna make two ads
that are really weird and one that is
like a nor just a
genuine ad for my channel and see which
one does better
and yeah one where i'm just like
spanking myself
that's me on a green screen i'm spanking
myself and the version of me that's
getting spanked is begging the viewer to
please subscribe to my channel
to make him stop spanking me and that
one that one did perform the best
i think because people were just so
shocked that they were like i gotta
click on
this guy's channel to figure out what
else his his content is about
i i would almost because you were
running that for like
a long time i would almost be
embarrassed because you're like
i want you to know why i'm doing this
but you won't find out for a little bit
because he was starting to get a bunch
of people being like [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] these ads because the ads were
going out to millions of people
he only got 40 subscribers from it that
is crazy
yeah it was awesome i do feel like
there's a good chunk of like
youtube's viewership that will never
watch my videos forever
because they just recognize you have to
also count the people you lost
like you get interesting
yeah i think that video did pretty well
i i made up for it in subscribers
because a lot of people saw the video
that never saw the ads but
i do have to wonder about the people
that saw that video
saw the ads and like will never [ __ ]
with me again
yeah which is you know kind of ironic
since you're actually just paying their
favorite
creators so that they can continue doing
it but i know and i got a lot of
comments too that were like
stop giving me ads i don't want any more
ads on youtube and it's like well
you know that if it wasn't my ad it
would just be someone else's right it's
like i'm not in control of all ads on
youtube
but it's so interesting you can actually
buy meme dumb for like
i do wonder how much tai lopez spent but
for
what a hundred you spent like thirteen
thousand dollars if you spend a hundred
thousand dollars
on just blasting your video out to
everybody on youtube you'll become
an a total me like an international meme
100 000 best marketing ever tai lopez
yeah let's talk about that guy i wonder
how that worked out for him i feel like
i mean he must have made a good amount
he was like selling a program or
something right about
dude he just bought pier one
you know pier one oh yeah they went
bankrupt he bought
the whole company for 31 million really
yeah okay he's doing good did i just go
to pier one
lopez owns pier one i went to some decor
store that was going out of business i
think it was pier one
how have i not heard of that it's just
the weirdest [ __ ] ever i mean i talked
about it with cody
oh and he's like i don't know how that's
gonna work out for him but he thinks
it's a great idea wait so that's outdoor
furniture
what is it what the [ __ ] is pure one
cell like [ __ ] just a bunch of crap
i thought it was just like interior
just foundations yeah it's like one of
those stores you walk in and just a
bunch of crap everywhere
and you walk through and you're like a
candy cane with candy canes in it
actually i'm not so i just went to pier
one i'm pretty sure that that
boat that little sailboat thing and that
picture frame right there
there you go that's exactly what i would
expect to find the caron
because we just went there because it's
going out of business so we were like
let's
clean up yeah i still haven't put a
picture in the picture frame but
i think it's a nice frame
yeah um
oh so i wanted to actually there's a
trending topic i want to talk to you
about because of your experience with
copyright and everything
you got in trouble with johnny johnny
yes papa of all people to get into a
copyright dispute
i would say he they are probably the
most intimidating
yeah that was super weird and i think to
this day they still have one of my
videos copyright claimed because somehow
they they claimed me and then i disputed
it and they released it and then like a
couple months later they claimed me
again for the same video for the same
content
i didn't even know you could do that i
thought like once it was resolved it's
resolved but
it should be yeah yeah that's happened
to me it's it's like okay
we've been over this but you can just
claim my [ __ ] again
so what happened with johnny johnny yes
papa what was the
are you familiar with that song yeah
johnny johnny yes papa
stealing candy no papa yeah
yeah it's a banger anyway yes so that's
yeah so that channel's billion surprise
toys i don't know if they
i don't know if they came up with that
song i think it was like a thing before
them because i feel or at least i've
seen it so many other places that i feel
like there's no way that they came up
with it i feel like it was like a
popular
like nursery rhyme or whatever before
that but
yeah they they made like these really
terrifying animated videos with that
song
just terrifying because the animation
was so bad and
they had like a bunch of other weird
stuff too so i just made a video about
them
and then they copyrighted my video and
then
they oh no they didn't copyright that
video and then i made another video
about them
where i sort of bragged about how
everyone else was getting copyright
claimed by them and i wasn't
and then they copyright claimed that
video but not the original one
no i don't think so oh that's so
interesting yeah
and i think they took down a lot of the
videos that i
talked about in that first video so the
only place you can see them is in my
video
yeah i was i was trying to find the
original uh
uh one one that all this dispute was
over all the hubbub and it's just not
there anymore
yeah i yeah i'm not sure what was up
with that i think they were just they
were getting goofed on by like pretty
much everyone so i feel like they were
trying to take down all the videos that
made them look like a
not a legitimate animation studio
which is apparent just by looking at it
i would say
yeah they're very good yeah so
anyway you may have heard that i don't
know if you followed this story that
critical
got a strike on his channel uh
for watching a road rage video
yes i didn't i haven't seen the actual
road rage
video but i've seen i saw markiplier's
video talking about it and i saw all of
uh moy's tweets the moist tweets
let's watch the video it's been youtube
said
we can watch this video now oh did they
yeah because they removed the strikes
ultimately
it's pretty funny though let me let me
tell the story before we watch this
so charlie got a community strike for
watching this video that we're gonna
watch
they said that it was uh
shocking and violent um and so
charlie was like yo what the [ __ ]
markiplier
reacted to the same video he tweeted
that kind of a snitch move by the way i
have to say
like just straight up kind of snitched
on mark
i guess so that sounds like something i
would do not realizing it's like a total
snitch thing
but then they took down markiplier's
video and they took down mark's video
well when i saw that i actually didn't
expect him to take down mark's he said
markiplier made a video laughing about
the same road rage instance when will he
be getting a strike
at team youtube straight up snitched on
him dude
like damn and so you just like a little
bit youtube's like you're right
and then they [ __ ] took down
they took down mark's video and gave him
a strike here
michelle do you think that that's
because
once because there's like youtube
moderators that are just like regular
people right that can report
videos do you think that it was it was
because so many people
it was brought to their attention and
they just went and reported it that it
got
taken down who knows what goes on back
there that's a that's a pretty plausible
explanation i would say yeah
i do think so yeah they just
some people got to see that one but they
didn't see that like someone like
markiplier reacted to it so
yeah i think charlie's fans probably
went mass flag in his video
because he snitched on him
anyway they were serving justice they
were like if charlie's video gets taken
down all right fine
yeah so mark said mark being a really
good sport said fair's fair where's my
strike
and then and then he said well there it
is [ __ ] strike does that
that's great uh fantastic
so actually even youtube responded to
him
this is just the classic youtube
messaging fiasco they go
they responded to charlie saying we
confirmed that it was reviewed by a team
member and the decision stands the
footage contains
graphic content with the intent to shock
wow i don't know if the intent is to
shock isn't it just people
in a fight like they weren't fighting to
shock people they were just fighting
right
i think i think chart whether it means
charlie showed it with the intent
oh i see yeah okay so
so anyway they went out to reverse it
let me show the tweet
i don't know if you can see it danny but
our audience can i cannot
he says i'm uh charlie said i'm
absolutely shocked youtube is deciding
to die on this hill
striking even the most wholesome creator
i wonder why
snitch what's next youtube
is every wwe video gonna be taken down
as well
yada yada so they updated they said
we're not gonna die in this hill you
were right
after further even further review
your video and others are back up these
strikes have been removed this was an
over
enforcement of our policy especially
with the added context you know i gotta
i gotta give it up so i haven't seen the
video too
get ready i don't think you read
criticals um
first to it about it but didn't doesn't
he say that the video is fake
right yeah but but like i mean again
that
i just don't think that's a distinction
you can make to youtube because
i mean how do you know it's fake are you
gonna prove it's fake but once you see
the video you'll see how ridiculous the
whole
fiasco is regardless of it being fake or
not i mean it is all kind of obviously
fake but
um let's watch
yeah let's do it i'm excited so dan how
do i um
how do we get her oh you you guys can do
it okay great can you see that danny
yes i can cool great all right here we
go this is
like the most fake fight i've ever seen
yeah yeah
no but i okay so i guess i can see some
the thing on youtube is that there's so
many people there enforcing and
that's a weird decision to give a strike
over that video dude they have
they have literally thousands of people
in india
who do this and so they're like oh
there's a dude getting stomped on the
ground
strike i think they
they err on the side of caution and then
once it gets but it's weird because i
even responded to his tweet saying like
yes this
action was correct yeah and again it's
because it's so
big like you have so this person who
runs a twitter account
is probably somewhere higher up in the
organization and they just quickly
reviewed it was like oh yes and we
reviewed this and said yeah
but then it goes even higher up with
someone with a brain is like
this is stupid so i feel like there's
there's there seems like so much
variation even amongst the thousands of
employees they have that like actually
review
the videos like because shocking and
violent content
is vague enough that you
you could interpret that differently if
you know there if there's thousands of
people that watch these videos i feel
like there's like a million different
ways you can interpret that so
yeah like every single person would
interpret that differently
i think if they're if there's even a
doubt then they go
they just kill it they're not [ __ ]
around anymore
i've had some pretty ridiculous claims
though what do you recall any of your
your uh favorite demonetizations
i no i don't get demonetized that much
they're the only times i get to monetize
i feel like is if i
if i swear in like the first 30 seconds
of the video that'll get you demonetized
um and then i feel like i did get one
video that was that got taken down
like totally taken down and i didn't
even get notified
about it like a community strike it
i don't think i i don't know if i got a
strike but it just like it went from
being public on my channel to like
not viewable anymore um because of
community guidelines like it was
the it was a video i did about um
like a couple prank channel and one of
the things that they did was like give
their
like sneak viagra into each other's
drinks or whatever which is a very
[ __ ] up thing to do
yeah and that was the point of my video
is to say it was [ __ ] up but
youtube was like actually you're [ __ ]
up for showing everyone it
uh and took it down but that happened to
us too
a lot of our old videos they go i get
arguments because i go
you literally you cannot see the
distinction between
calling out bad behavior policing
content and the actual act itself
and you know what their answer is they
say no there's no distinction
they literally say that yeah well the
weird thing about
that is then sometimes the original
video stays up and yours gets ticked
yeah that's about it that's always a
good that always feels good
well um i wanted to play a little bit of
a
game with you that i thought was right
up your alley called
influencers in the wild are you familiar
with this phenomenon
i don't think so so what this is is when
people spot
influencers doing weird and wild [ __ ]
in the wild getting over okay so so i've
got
nine of the top influencers in the wild
here
influencers in the wild and we're going
to do a tier list together
oh all right let's do it okay we are
going to go to a quick break when we
come back more with danny gonzalez
today i want to tell you about ring
ring is one of my favorite tech products
is changed
it's it's such a good product okay when
we
lived at our last house we were getting
so much trouble so much crap going on
around our house
you know how hard and complicated it is
to install security cameras and do all
that
the thing is that ring by the way is
like a tenth of the price probably even
cheaper
but the thing is it's also connected to
the wi-fi so when someone comes
in the ring of security that's why it's
called rangilo
is that it sends out a motion detector
and
uploads it automatically to the internet
so if some creep coming
snooping on your [ __ ] cutting your
electricity or whatever
goddamn it's all up on the on the cloud
and it saves those clips so it's super
easy to find the moments of
uh suspicious activity dude when we were
when we were in our last neighborhood
people like everyone in our neighborhood
was getting robbed
and the police one time came to my door
and they're like hey did you see
anything around this time
boom ring i saw the car on my ring on my
ring spotlight in the driveway
yeah on the actual security cameras it's
almost like
impossible to find a specific moment
those things are so easy
it really is i mean ring is the future i
feel like that old
stuff is just over ring has a security
product for every corner of your home
inside and out
best of all you can see it all in one
simple app
with the ring you can keep an eye on
your home no matter where you are right
from your phone
if someone stops by or something's going
on ring lets you know it's a peace of
mind
anytime knowing that your home is
protected that's another thing
you open your app because it's all
online no matter where you are you see
all the cameras
right and you can talk through the
cameras you can hit an alarm through the
cameras
uh it's phenomenal um
it genuinely felt made me feel so much
safer
the thing is also cool about ring is
they have a neighborhood app so
everybody in your area
can goss up and talk about what's going
on in the neighborhood and it's really
cool as well and they can share videos
and uh and pictures and stuff through
that
through their ring app it's great
whatever you call it
ring has something to protect it
you can see and speak to whoever's at
your door from anywhere with the video
doorbell
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras protect your
whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself
now uh with our link get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit
at ring.com h3 it comes with rings video
doorbell 3
and chime pro the perfect way to start
your ring experience
plus free two day shippings so guys
if you want to support the show and get
a beautiful product at the same time go
to ring.com
h3 that's ring.com h3
okay and we're back so
here is our first influencer in the wild
by the way this is all from an account
influencer in the well so there's
someone much very dedicated to this
so shout out to them yeah did
does this person have a lot of followers
it's got 90 000. i think it's pretty big
let's see influencer in the wild 3.5
million god damn
and so you guys went through and these
were your favorite posts
yeah all right
here we go there's a ton more on there
too so yeah yeah this person is prolific
yeah because people submit them to them
they email them so
yeah all right here we go uh
oh no
oh that oh that's just a straight up
tick tock though that went wrong
yeah but i i was going to say this
doesn't look like very candid because
the person filming her
is supposed to be but it's still great
i mean i'd love to see that you know if
you're just walking by
yeah it's kind of sad all around because
nobody's proposing to her
and then she's just really eating [ __ ]
i've seen people do this trend on tick
tock before and i don't even know if
you're supposed to walk backwards i
think the camera person is supposed to
walk back she was improvising
yeah this is awesome i mean i could
watch it
a lot so what is the trend because i'm
not familiar with it
it's this it's like a remix of this
taylor swift song
and you do the little proposal thing and
then the the cameraman starts walking
away
and then the beat drops and then you do
like a dance where you thrust your hips
i think is the whole thing
that did not that's not what happened in
this one
well that was fantastic so okay again i
always have trouble with the first one
you know because we have no point of
reference
yeah but here she is can you see that
i i have some issues here i mean first
of all it's not a candid
shot yeah right yeah that's what i was
going to say it doesn't seem really true
to the
this is pretty safe let's just start c
and
number two we've got a backflip
faceplant that sounds good to me
hopefully it's not too shocking for
youtube right
yeah this might be violent and shocking
yeah
okay this one looks candid so here we go
yeah it's almost like making me rethink
face plants in general like that's
really the only way to get a good face
plan is by doing a backflip into it
right oh my god
he kind of like he kind of like twerks
at the end i don't know if you can see
that but
yeah right he jiggles at the end
it looks like he meant to do it it's
like he's it's like he just surrendered
like
halfway through the flip he's like [ __ ]
it because like his arms go limp
like before he hits the ground he's like
[ __ ] this i'm out
yeah it's like you know how sometimes
when people go in like in jet planes the
g-force is too much and they pass out
right
it's like that happened in the middle of
his flip yeah
oh man we love it we love to see it but
there you have it that one
let's let's pull it up
well it's candid it's definitely higher
up than
you want to give it up what do we think
gonna be maybe yeah i'm tempted to give
it higher than the first one
because it's candid and uh and
i like that you can actually see when he
hits the ground because the girl who
fell the first time
you don't even really get to see what
happens to her true that's a really good
idea
disappears into the shrubs right that's
a really fantastic point
all right oh no so wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait-wait let's see ones like this
before
these are always bad i'm gonna mute it
just so i don't like
destroy your audio okay here we go yeah
you know when there's a
rope swing involved it's already going
to be bad
rope swing swing accidents are the
absolute worst
and there's nothing to hold on to on
that rope like she's just holding onto
the rope
i don't think people appreciate how hard
it is to just hold on to a rope
yeah and especially like a thin rope
there's no there's no
knot or anything yeah it's so thin uh
here we go buckle up
that's not what i expected at all
wait she doesn't let go dude we were
giving her
we were talking so much [ __ ] like she
wasn't going to be able to hold on but
that's the only thing she did right
it was her camera person oh
and then i love how she like destroyed
her camera person and then wouldn't even
let go of the rope did she reach her
legs out to kick the camera person
yes
wait i gotta hear the audio on this
can you hit me with the audio again
[Laughter]
it does make me wonder what was the
intention
at all i know it looks like she just
kicks her friend
like into the abyss and then she just
chills on the rope for a while she's
like well while i'm here i might just
like she pushes herself off the rock
again she's like i might as well just
wow that one's really good although it
makes me just
it kind of i just really wonder what was
the intention
i think she was trying to get an action
shot and she was trying to retract her
legs last minute
her legs kind of come closer like she
was trying not to kick her butt
she could literally kick her at like
straight up
kicked her i mean you see how she flies
off man that was like a full force flow
yeah if that was me maybe my instincts
would be to reach out my legs so i don't
hit her with my whole body
and maybe i can like slow myself down
with my legs
but it really does look like that was
entirely intentional
oh i love it she's like yo can you do me
a favor and film just get a shot at me
real quick
and then all of a sudden right in front
of me please
that's awesome i love it well this one
wow
that was great that one was better in my
opinion
yeah what do we think
i'm thinking that's the best one so far
yeah i guess it's an a we have to save
esther for something really
fantastic yeah yeah i don't like to um
i don't like to give away s tier too
easily these are almost like merging
into one
great photo i think it's a good t-shirt
potentially for merch
you know yeah that's kind of cool
just like this long design of people
about to get rocked okay
oh boy oh no what do we think just on
the pause
here oh it's got a lot almost a million
views
this is giving me someone's gonna fall
on the road for sure
do you think this guy is gonna rear-end
them because that's what i'm worried
about and then they go flying or
something
[Music]
i don't think he's going to be at fault
you know i think they're just
first of all what are they doing why
they're on the roof of a volkswagen and
traffic
what the [ __ ] yeah these like yoga
influencers
it looks like a yoga pose kinda oh i
don't know
i didn't even know there was yoga
answers
all right here we go
oh what are they doing over there
no this is that's the same that's the
same trend as the first girl
really oh it is yeah they're doing the
proposal thing oh my god this
trend is like destroying society
oh so no oh so nothing happened it's
just embarrassing
yeah yeah yeah well it's embarrassing if
they got wiped out by a car
yeah that would be violent and shocking
i don't understand the trend why
why do they propose and then run and
then do that do that i don't get it
see here's my theory is there's no point
to it and this trend started right
before taylor swift released her most
recent album
i feel like this was an inside job by
taylor swift because it's a taylor swift
zone
that's my theory i don't have anything
to back it up other than the timing but
how do you even think of something like
that like it's just it doesn't make any
sense
that's tick-tock man don't you
understand it doesn't make any sense
i i don't know what to do with this
yeah i i mean i didn't make the videos
like you're proposing or being proposed
to what is the story
yeah because the line it's the it's from
the taylor swift song
love story and the line is he knelt to
the ground and pulled out a ring and
said juliet marry me
so you're like doing the proposing and
then you dance
and then they're like and then you dance
it's a remix to the song so there's like
a beat drop and you dance so i'm
subscribing to the conspiracy theory i
think he's right
i think it's a viral taylor swift
marketing oh
i think that's a really good theory i
just i don't know how you can
force such a nonsensical trend how can
you get people to do something that
makes no
sense if you pay popular tick tockers to
start doing it then everyone says is
that what happens
yeah i think i mean generally speaking
that's a thing that happens with like
popular songs and stuff this artist will
just play take talkers
man i are you on tech talk are you
active on there i'm
i'm really not and i feel like i should
be i'm not
super active i post like occasionally
and um i watch tick tock a lot
like laura and i just lay on the couch a
lot
in the evening and watch tick tock for
like an hour see i feel like we have to
do that you know
i just feel that i'm missing out on yeah
might be something going on although i
can do it is someone buying a tick tock
because it may be
yeah i know i don't want to get invested
just yet i want to wait till i know it's
going to exist
yeah you don't want to fall in love with
that right to have it
as i understand it we have we'll find
out in about two weeks
well the deadline the original deadline
was september 15th i believe
which uh yeah is week after next and
there was news earlier this week that um
china changed the rules
that and that it might now block the
sale so
uh there's a decent chance it's going to
get banned wow
yeah the newest update would be so crazy
i know it should be unbelievable
uh there's a there yeah the newest
development is that china
is stepping in because they want to make
sure
i guess they want to make sure that like
it's about the algorithm yeah any of the
ai or they don't want they don't want to
give away the secret of the algorithm
they
don't want to give away the info i think
why would someone buy it if they're not
getting the algorithm they want the
audience they want the platform
i know the algorithm is really important
they would they would want a functioning
platform right
yeah yeah i mean that's like the whole
thing that's the reason tick-tock is
good is because you don't have to follow
it like i don't follow barely anyone on
tick tock
i just scroll on my for you page and
good stuff comes to me
did i hear that walmart is considering
buying it walmart i heard that it's
they were partnering with microsoft i
believe yeah i didn't understand that
i was just thinking is that even gonna
be walmart related now i don't know
i just feel like it's gonna go down to
[ __ ] like walmart owns it
no algorithm that [ __ ] is gonna just
like there are already so many walmart
versions of tick-tock that like imagine
if walmart
really did just own tick-tock dude
everything
has done a bunch of trends on tick-tock
more than any other company to my
knowledge
really oh really they got scammed what
so what's a walmart trend look like
uh it depends like they had a christmas
one where it was like for
christmas shopping they're all over the
place
you proposed to walmart and then when
the beat drops you start like thrusting
your hips
exactly dan i have the tier thing up but
can you see them
on the user side when they talk yeah
okay i have zoom open on oh great great
great great great great great great
greg greg greg greg greg greg
all right well i gotta tell you [ __ ]
these people i'm gonna give them a d
what do you guys think yeah yeah well
there was a small detail that i want to
point out that i think we all missed in
that is there appears to be
some sort of forest fire going on on the
side of the road oh what
okay wait let me revisit it that way i
do need to revisit in that case
i think that might be why the traffic is
happening
look
that's bizarre too you gotta wonder how
that's not the focal point of the tick
tock if there's a forest fire going on
right
next to you and you're like well let's
just make a video to taylor swift's song
because they're like oh we got this
freeway that's not moving
great chance to dance between cars
yeah i really hope that that's their car
that they jump on
you imagine if there's just other people
in there yeah
it has to be i can't even imagine
but i do yeah the fact that there's a
fire fire forest fire whatever's going
on over there it's definitely juicy but
i still hate them and think they deserve
a d
yeah see it is do we all agree
yeah it's just secondhand embarrassment
there's no like pizzazz to it so
yeah there's no tumbling off of a cliff
but i'm liking the imagery here it's
really powerful
it's really good it is really good uh
number five
guy voice over influencer shoot
there it is there you go
hell yeah okay she could be doing more
to be honest but
honestly what he's doing is pretty good
show her
let's see what she thinks yeah come to
him dude so that he doesn't have to get
out of the pool and then back in the
pool
oh man the look of shame he hopes that
she likes it so he can stop taking
pictures dude
he probably took 46 by now maybe 50.
there you go
there it is there yeah i know that pain
that guy nailed it man that happened
like a surprising amount when we
we used to live in la for a couple years
and we
lived our apartment building we lived
like right outside the pool and i would
always see like people taking pictures
like that by the pool
or in the hot tub why do you
i know you live in uh chicago i believe
right
yeah i live in like the suburbs of
chicago so why did you leave la
um i mostly just moved there because i
thought it was like the spot for social
media
or just like everything in general
because that was like we moved there
when
i was doing vine still and vine got shut
down
right and i but i had like a full-time
job there also
but i mostly just moved back home
because well this is where my parents
live and also where laura's parents live
so once i started making enough on
youtube where like i didn't have to be
didn't feel like i had to be in la or i
didn't have to have like a full-time job
elsewhere
that's interesting you just moved back
home when you found the success you
wanted
yeah i feel like i kind of did like the
reverse you yeah because most people
moved to l.a well they started
my family i'm going to l.a
yeah that's one of the weird things that
i've always felt about youtube
is that like you can live anywhere and
do youtube it's just weird to me that so
many people congregate to l.a
uh even people who have no hopes of like
entering like the hollywood scene
or the movie industry people just
flocked to la
even though you can do this job from
anywhere i guess there's better
resources out there
like it took me a while to find people
to like film stuff out here with
yeah well yeah there's there's a lot of
resources and
if you want to like collab with people
they're here yeah
that's true if you want to pay way more
taxes this is a good place to come
illinois is actually not great on taxes
so it's probably about the same
really yeah i think illinois i forget if
it's income tax or property tax but it
i think it's income tax illinois is like
second in the
nation or something like that shout out
to illinois let's go
yeah it's awesome so this one i'm not
super impressed by frankly
pretty pedestrian it's a d
yeah it's just kind of
it's just kind of secondhand
embarrassment just like that the other
one
yeah it's a dude i could go d i mean
this girl falling off the cliff is
yeah i'm starting to appreciate her a
lot more now should we go back let's
watch her
that's true was that tarzan girl no this
was
backflip the first one oh was the first
one it was the first one let's go ahead
and revisit this one because again i
like you said i'm beginning to
appreciate it a little more
yeah we've seen this challenge
ah man she's not very
aware of her surroundings wow she really
just
does disappear completely like she
is gone that's true not even a leg still
showing
look at her i mean that's got to be a
steep drop off
look at her face the moment it hits the
stone
yeah this one's good man we got to move
this girl up
yeah we can move it up she died
yeah it's crazy that she's dead now man
i can't we miss her
i miss her let's move her ass up to uh
the thing is it's not candid so i can't
really give it better than it be
but what do you think i mean i'm willing
to negotiate obviously
now i think b's i think that fits pretty
good yeah yeah
i like that the a tier belongs in the a
tier because it had like levels to it
yeah there were there were lots of good
things about that 100
it was candid it was there was like
injuries the cameraman took a dunk
it was weird how long she held onto the
exactly
come on okay influencer climbing horse
alrighty sounding good to me
dude i'm going to start faking vines
where i
just from the third person have someone
pretending to
[ __ ] up making a vine just to get
featured on this account yeah exactly
meta [ __ ] dude i'm gonna fake faking it
i'm gonna fake [ __ ] it up candidly
well that's probably already happening
considering how big this account
is yeah i wonder that's a good point
yeah i wonder how many layers you could
add like
[ __ ] it up candid and then you're
recording the guy who's recording them
and he falls
these all remind me of that girl who
um what was she it was like during the
black lives matter protest she would
like was pretending to help with
something like help board up a window or
something and then she got
her mercedes and drove away wait you
guys gotta pull
could you guys pull those up those ones
are great there's like black lives
matter
influencers would they like pull up with
a sign and then bounce immediately after
taking a photo oh
yeah can you guys find some of those
right like we got to add those to the
list maybe just add them
to the bottom good call danny those are
important
oh yeah what are you doing you're on a
public sculpture in a fountain i mean
what the
[ __ ] oh yeah
i mean that's so rude yeah yeah
it's so douchey and i love that she just
ate it hard
only i know it's funny that you thought
that would work because like there's not
anything to grab onto and she's wearing
like the slipperiest clothes possible
and that horse is like looks like very
slippery also
in the morning in public like how
embarrassing
yeah how do you live with yourself well
that probably
hurt quite a bit because that's iron and
it snagged her leg
she got it oh yeah she went in and i
oh and she did oop wait so is there a
good sound here
good question
that looks super painful she deserved it
[Music]
oh man imagine having friends like that
yeah it sounds like her friend was only
a bad influence
yeah more like a bad influencer
zing bruh
um where does it go so let's think here
she's obviously awful she ate [ __ ]
the ironic things about these is like
they
all the people at the start of these
videos were probably like oh this is
going to kill on my social media
yeah and then it totally goes wrong but
then it ends up on an account like this
and it does kill but like for the wrong
reason
it probably did way better than it would
have if it went right
this girl was probably like this picture
of me on a horse at the mall or wherever
the [ __ ] she is is gonna
absolutely kill on my instagram
are you thinking a c um
well maybe a b
i don't know it could definitely be a c
because like
i would i would lean for c because when
i think of
like the face plant and bee like that's
a good hit
yeah i feel like when she actually
landed it wasn't like that satisfying
right right even though she probably
endured a lot of pain
oh yeah not a great watch it makes me
appreciate the face playing guy kind of
too
after going through these because that
there was some layers there
yeah like how his ass jiggle that was
pretty cool
yeah i didn't want to say that but no
yeah i noticed that
um yeah i think a c what do you think
eila yeah
yeah poseidon's wrath i like that
what that wave looks so crazy oh no
shout out to brittany nash
who apparently this is spelled the most
obnoxious way oh yeah whoa the ie
brittany brittany dude that wave is so
way too big how is she just casually
standing there like
that is a huge wave holy crap
dude so this is great is this one
actually candid because
she's posing in that other direction
right to someone else
oh you might well they got wiped out too
yeah they did
i think no i think it's not candid i
think she just thought it was gonna wash
over her gently
and she was gonna look sexy i don't know
if she's never been to the beach before
or something
well the interesting thing about this is
she might actually still get a good
picture from this like if
you just go a couple of frames before
she gets hit like that's a dope picture
right there
so you think she knew yeah oh but then
she's really committed to her
vacation then she's a good client
she's on x games mode because she knew
she was gonna get hurt she did it anyway
wow i hate the ocean bro [ __ ] the ocean
i used to go i grew up in socal man and
in ventura and there's some pretty
you get waves like this all the time
yeah it's
it's so surprising how hard water can be
when it hits you like that
i mean yeah that that's
that's a lot of water oh man yeah she
slammed into the ground too
like it didn't just knock her forward it
knocked her
down that's just sand right there
yeah we used to go to the oceans like
every summer i would go to a summer camp
and they'd make us go to the beach i
[ __ ] hated it
because it's like you go to have a good
time at the beach but all the waves are
like
terrifying yeah and so in israel it's
not like that it's like a
it's like a bath yeah well in israel you
got jealous
oh yeah do you guys like the beach in
california that's one thing that i was
like excited about when i moved to
california and then just like every time
i went
i was not happy with it it's cold
it's scary it's really sharks it's just
such a different experience
for me what i'm used to is like people
go
to the beach and it's a it's a really
fun time like you go in the water it's
warm
uh i don't know and then here it's like
kind of dangerous
and cold no it's horrible
yeah even like it's really beautiful
here we lived in glendale
and there would be days where it'd be
like 100 degrees and then we would go to
the beach and at the beach it'd be like
70 degrees yeah you need a jacket so
much cooler
well glendale windy yeah that's the
weird thing about la is like
in glendale or the valley it can be 100
degrees you go to the beach
it's freezing so first of all it's cold
the water is cold
the water is always freezing here but it
it is
really beautiful here there's like so
much
nature it's pretty amazing yeah that's
true you know
when you get to see jellyfish here you
get
seals just hanging out yeah on the sand
saying hi to you
and stuff dolphins yeah it's crazy yeah
flesh eating uh bacteria
water yeah that happens too
i i've never do you know what i'm
talking about no the beaches they get
shut down
fairly frequently because of some sort
of uh septic
thing got released into it or whatever
oh oh well that's
i remember seeing something about like
huntington beach being really dirty or
something like that
yeah or maybe it was santa well there's
a lot of boats and
uh yeah the marinas are disgusting i
wouldn't swim in those
i've watched this like a thousand times
i'm just watching
santa barbara there's tar all over the
place oh yeah there's a guitar on your
feet
so wait is that a natural occurrence is
that just from offshoring
there's like an oil tanker yeah or oil
drilling
oh that's disgusting yeah so yes
we love our beaches when i was little
um like eight years old my family lived
in england for two years
and every time we would go to the beach
there
the beach would like it wouldn't be sand
it would just be like rocks like
rocks like this big so it wouldn't be
like fine gravel
i've seen that it's just yeah which is
pretty unpleasant like you can't have a
nice day like laying out at the beach
when
you're there's just like big rocks right
i guess that does go
uh that counts for something the the
sand is really nice on the
on the west coast in israel it's even
more
like it's just really soft and
wow if we want to go to the beach we go
to like lake michigan
the great lakes stuff like that um
and those are nice because the ocean is
so big that it takes forever to warm up
but lakes
are kind of smaller so i guess they warm
up quicker so they're usually not as
cold as the ocean
does it freeze over in the winter
some parts of lake michigan do i'm
pretty sure yeah
and my grandpa uh he grew up in
in chicago and he would tell us about
how much he [ __ ] hated it there oh
really
he's just like it's cold it's windy it's
hot in the summer
he's just complaining about it sounds
really cool to me yeah
i agree i mean i really like
the seasons that's like one thing i
missed when i lived in la
is because i feel like i guess there's
seasons like in
january there's it's definitely
different than in like july but in
general it's like very
condensed um but here you get everything
right but you also get like months of
bitter cold so that's just
yeah the chicago winter is pretty
serious uh can you see what i'm saying
yes oh
my god
dude that's shocking and violent right
there yeah that is shocking and violent
but can we blame the ocean when i go to
the beach here
so this one's pretty good i think and
also i kind of admire her
i kind of think you're right i think
she's just a hero right i think so too
yeah i mean maybe she didn't expect it
to be so bad but i think she knew like
okay i'm going to get hit by this wave
so i think we got to give her some kudos
i'm team
natalie team natalie nash
did you guys find any black lives matter
influencers yeah it's in discord
oh can you add it to my list i'm working
on uh sure
thank you oh look at this thumbnail
that oh yeah okay well let's
let's think here that's going straight
on our instagram it's not as good as a
let's be honest right
well you think it's a tier
it is good i'm open the a
maybe the a is an s though because that
one had it all
it did i feel like we won't know until
the end if a is an s
right right
i could go i could go b for sure it's a
pretty strong b
definitely strong b let's do b then
because
like it's not as good as this one i mean
it's just not all righty
poseidon's wrath uh simon cowell of tick
tock
i don't know what that means let's find
out
uh just how unentertained he is
that's awesome what a legend
oh that's so sad like they're really
giving it their all
they've got a perfect background they
got the choreography down
and he's just like
dude he's on a boat man you got to step
your [ __ ] up
what kind of out of sync they're out of
sync
exactly yeah get your [ __ ] together
come on ladies what are we doing here i
love that even without the audio like
you
you can't tell what's going on yeah this
is the best thing ever
this is pretty epic yeah i agree
they're trying so hard also i mean
it didn't look that bad you know
looking pretty good gila they're
striving for perfection they got the
boat it's a perfect day
they've been exercising just think it's
not just tick-tock
do you think they rented the boat just
for this i'm thinking i'm thinking
probably
yeah this is what this is why they're
there
yeah looks like the whole day is about
this
i mean i don't know how much is it as
much as it looks like he's not into it
i feel like if he wasn't into it he
would have just been like that was good
we can be done but he like he cares
about it but maybe he cares
too much well the way i'm interpreting
it is that
this is his project yeah he's this is
all
this is what you know what i mean that's
why he cares
this is his idea
dude i need like i need this gif i need
to be able to use that in some regard
okay i like that one can he by the way
can you see this
me no he oh he won't no
sorry nevermind it's just in the
switcher i have a button of a guy
from sonic who was delivering food and
i saw that yeah yeah
so where do we put this guy i like him a
lot
yeah i like his oh there was i don't
know if
this might be in the list but there was
one recently that was like super popular
on twitter that was like these
that was a dude um it looked like a
group of friends at like a
some fast food place where you order
outside and the
the woman who's working like calls his
name or something
and he starts to do because his friend
is filming him he starts to do something
like really dramatic where he's like
did you say and then the woman who's
working is like no shut up just come get
your food and the kid immediately he's
like
okay yeah i'll come get it you guys
should try to find that one and add it
to my list
sure our list is growing yeah i don't i
saw it on twitter but
i feel like that's descriptive enough
well i mean
it's a c if i'm being honest well well
how are you going to compare it with
this look at this
well you want to up make an argument i'm
here to listen
we did get some laughs out of it yeah we
got a lot of laughs
that's it
you guys want to put this baby
but just just remember who and whose
company you're putting it
face planned falling to the death rest
in peace we miss her
no we don't don't forget her and where
yeah i think b-tier is exclusively for
people who died during the video
right b stands for uh
all right we can move them down there's
no good
i mean look you know i'm just i'm trying
to get
i'm trying to be as serious as i can
here oh bye stands for bye bye
bye bye i'll see you in the afterlife
yeah no i mean but i hear your point
though it's better than the bowl
because maybe these need to move down
like [ __ ] these guys yeah
maybe we need like a c and a half tier
yeah or we could these guys suck
there she's d and i think maybe yeah
maybe this is a true c
okay okay i would even put the card
dancing one to f
um right that's a good point zach i mean
what are we doing here
way too like this one had some
entertainment value right but this one
was just like [ __ ] these people
yeah yeah yeah yeah
nice interesting what may way well
happen is this is
s and these are a but we'll find out
yeah yeah that's entirely possible hair
flip generation
hmm i feel like i know what's going to
happen in this video
yeah it kind of gives it away but here
we go
so she got her hair wet to flip it
okay and
you gotta love it you gotta love it
probably got the photo though yeah
yeah that's another one where it seems
like they got the photo that they were
probably going for
right i'm so glad that they filmed it
too
i i like that she's got her ballerina
shoes on she's doing the tiptoe thing
which almost seems to me like a show of
balance like look how balanced i
am right while i do this yeah
and it turns out she wasn't so balanced
after all look at that
form grace look how beautiful she is
yeah what's that vin diesel
look how beautiful she is yeah she's
pretty
not very balanced though not very good
at tick tock yeah
do you have one of vin diesel saying
she's not very balanced
the diesel is she balanced so [ __ ]
sexy it's not i can't do it
again yeah he genuinely comments on the
appearance
uh wow okay
um hmm i'm thinking
cb or c which means we don't have an s
here
[Music]
okay uh my
thinking is that she probably she didn't
die so
not b yeah that's there you go
done no death
step your [ __ ] up all right now we're
moving
we're moving on to black lives matter
influencers
is there any way i can get a picture of
them so i can put them on the uh tier
list dan
holy sh you can just screenshot it real
quick this
has 29 million views
yeah wow that's the one okay
i have a feeling this is gonna be high
up this lady stopped someone boarding up
a store in santa monica
so she could hold the drill for a
picture and then drove away
holy [ __ ] wow what
i do remember seeing that and her dad
it's like her dad is filming
oh this is so embarrassing this is
is that she's wearing her mask for the
picture and the second the picture's
over she also takes off her mask
this is so awesome i can't even
i can't handle this
dad what are you doing how did you talk
your dad into doing this
holy [ __ ]
bro good job everybody
oh my god oh my god you i can't
you this is the most embarrassing thing
i've ever seen yeah yeah
it's so weird because like what was this
picture supposed to look like were we
really supposed to believe that this
dude who's like clearly
dressed in construction uniform it's
like working with this
girl dressed in like regular clothes
somehow they
came together and they're putting up
these boards this guy will never forget
this moment
holy [ __ ] wow i ah
i'm speechless frankly that s tier then
so i think i think it's ester
ester by far this one transcends
yes i've almost never been so
embarrassed before
for somebody you know and i i wonder
because they got the even the license
plate you saw the dad you saw her i mean
this has 30 million views everyone she
knows saw this
it sounds like they were getting shamed
while it was happening also like the
person i was filming was like wow nice
job guys as they were driving off it's
like
it's not just secondhand embarrassment
like they're getting shamed in the video
for it
how did she get the dad to do this like
parents before they stopped me from
doing this [ __ ]
but he was such a willing participant
like well imagine the inner dialogue dad
pull over
i want to get a photo with that guy's
drill
and then imagine having the balls to
approach someone who's doing work be
like hey can i borrow your drill and
take a photo real fast
yeah that's crazy and it's like good job
i'm proud of you for being so involved
in social
together we can make a change yeah you
really made a difference today sweetie
good call wow well we have more black
lives matter influencers let's see
so far they're [ __ ] great
here we go this one says
um okay
oh this is the this is a twitter account
for influencers in the wild
oh this person is really prolific i
gotta say
here we go audio up
uh what
what that looks like jamie heinemann
from mythbusters
oh no no bruh
well i mean is he okay
he's just trying to get a cool photo can
he yeah i mean he's at the protest i
don't know that he's not necessarily
there in earnest
yeah he's not wearing a mask though
which is kind of whack yeah
you gotta wear a mask down there
definitely cause the thing is like if
you don't wear a mask down there you
you give everybody that you make
everyone look bad
yeah it does seem weird to like turn it
into a photo shoot though like that
i mean he brought like his nice k he's
got his camera bag on
like he's there just to take pictures
well it might
be something that he does so his outfit
is bothering me too to be honest
there were just the the imagery in
general was very
surreal so yeah
i mean he's a very interesting looking
person yeah i think jamie
it's embarrassing on the level
no the other girl the other girl was
again transcendent let's get a nice
photo of him with his hands up
dude look how good i am in photoshop
beautiful
what a king all right we've got uh we've
got
jamie from mythbusters young uh
the young monopoly guy we've got uh
the poster boy of manscaping
where does he go do you let me ask you
something do you use the same
trimmer on your pubes as you use on your
face
me yes no no
you don't seem like the type of dude who
would do that now
to be honest i don't shave very often
anyway but when i do it's not with the
same thing that i use on my balls
so so you do you do trim
on your your pubes occasionally
that's good i think you're i think
that's i think it's appreciated
thanks for asking yeah what about you
well i'll be honest with you
um it's not unheard of that i'll go
i'll go face to pew but the same
instrument
face to pube sounds like you're trimming
your pubes with your face yeah
that just sounds good well i just wanted
to make it clear that i do the face
first
and then the pubes but you would still
use it later
yeah no no i agree it's not optimal but
i take a shower out
full circle yeah i like that you
acknowledge that it's not ideal but you
do it anyway it's not ideal
no it's not ideal i mean by any means
it's not ideal because what are you
gonna do buy two razors
i mean that seems over this seems
ridiculous i believe you have already
a couple of them so you could do it but
that doesn't make sense does it not
seem ridiculous be like here's my pube
razer and here's my face right here it's
like wow first world problem dude just
cut your hair bro
i think it's fine if you go to the shop
exactly i go to the shower
but uh what do i know well you kissed me
i haven't smelled anything on your face
anyway i bet this guy goes uh face to
pube for sure
i think he's got like five different
trimmers yeah that guy is pretty
yeah he's probably got like an arsenal
of different like little scissors and
stuff mustache oil
so embarrassing
it's a d i think or maybe even eight ah
hmm oh and that's kind of wrong i mean i
like the way the guy made me feel and
that makes me want to rank him
poorly but i don't know if that's just
me i feel the same way i mean
i'm thinking e i could see that
yeah i don't i didn't like how he made
me feel i know what you mean why are you
shocked by that dan what do you think
not just it's harsh critics here but oh
you got to be when you're when you're
creating a tier list this is serious
business
yeah yeah well i think we all thought we
were being too nice before because we're
putting everything in b-tier
right right and i feel pretty good about
how everything's landed these bees are
solid
but these are special yeah i kind of i
am i kind of feel like the girl that
disappears into the black hole should be
a
no but it's not candid dan yeah that's
the problem
right we're docking it for that okay
okay fair enough he is like the beat
beat-up tier
okay so but to be fair if the instagram
account's not called
candid influencers it's called
influencers in the wild and she
literally does
disappear into the wilderness maybe we
misunderstood
the whole thing no but
i don't know that is a good point
there's a good number of these where
they are like in the wild though like
the one girl who gets
destroyed by the ocean dude on the beach
let me ask you this
do you think that this is as good as
this one
because i don't i mean yeah this one
is next this one is elevated i think
it's elevated
you know but maybe this one's s here
maybe that's the problem
yeah it's weird well like that might be
and then that
that might be here because what i was
gonna say is i think that the girl
falling into the abyss
is better than the other b-tier ones but
not as good as that a tier one
yeah yep yeah i think we figured it out
oh
i think we unlocked all right good call
yeah good job everyone oh well
i feel i feel like i just screwed a
screw into a uh
black lives matter protest now we can
get in our mercedes
i was going to say we almost got like a
big f here
oh wow but the guy kind of messes it up
yeah from chat it's like a double decker
f kind of
now i want to taco bell was that all the
clips we got
no we have more oh we do oh i thought
that was it
oh wait is this the last one i saw
someone typing no
we have one more okay linkedin photo
shoot what the [ __ ] does that mean
oh no uh
now is not the time for a new linkedin
profile page
oh my god are you kidding me here we go
[Applause]
wow that's pretty funny
is that like senior photos or something
what's going on over there
that is pretty funny i gotta say man
this guy is just like i don't care
what's going on in the world i scheduled
this and i'm doing it
does it have to be this alley that's so
weird
is that do you think that's his dad he
his back looks so sweaty
like they've been out there for hours
taking these pictures you think that's
it
i don't i don't think they look related
you know there's no very
different yeah i guess they'd be oh [ __ ]
i thought he was wearing a backpack dude
i think he is oh oh do you oh maybe he
is
it's just like so close to his shirt
color that i thought it was sweat
is this a kid or a man is it ladies and
men
it might be his dad man control plus
oh what is the what is the thing on the
wall saying next to him fun
yeah that's what i wanted oh yeah fun
while it lasted i think
[ __ ] i think it's a graduation photo it
does look like it
oh totally senior portraits so they
planned this out
before the protest yeah it's just weird
that they were like well there's like a
big protest going on downtown
like in the exact area we wanted to take
our pictures but we'll just go anyway
wow i love it
did he really not weigh today the [ __ ]
no dude he's graduating
he's only going to look that fresh once
it was fun while it lasted
that's right i mean he probably only had
the suit they probably reserved the suit
you know you rent that [ __ ] hmm
everyone is located it does look like
the
there's like a girl standing on the
sidelines taking a picture of them too
yeah i think it's just it's just a hell
of a sight yeah
yeah man i love it
i love it i love it donald loves it
i said i love it okay i like it
wow rave reviews even the president
okay even the president could get behind
this so what do we think about
uh graduating in the apocalypse
it's a funny concept but i don't know if
i like
i'm just saying you know i'm just sizing
it don't panic i'm not placing it
i think it's a c but it might be a d
it's better than d yeah
okay we can put it in c yeah
okay yeah i feel like it fits
yeah because
[ __ ] this girl i love this guy
this freaking guy all the way down there
and eating with his hands up
all right finally this is our final one
and um it's on youtube unusually
how odd should i mute this damn wait
that's not
in the wild well neither was the girl
who fell to
oblivion either no it is a fail it's a
candid fail
okay okay here we go oh my god i
the title yeah i know i kind of gave it
away
maybe it wonder at what point should i
play the music
[Music]
i don't need the slaw
dude her leg is so limp how did that
happen
yeah so i think there's a description
here
oh she's auditioning for
a tic she's a tick tock sensation she's
famous
this music audition made her a tick tock
sensation
yeah her name is liz she was doing a
tick tock and her mom was
upstairs and supposedly she missed like
the support beams and just went straight
through
oh so she was in like an attic yeah
exactly
that's awesome wow the fact that she was
on tick tock when it happened is epic
wait i still don't understand how could
that happen she's in the attic yeah
and sh well apparently there's certain
parts of the attic that you have to use
the support beams because there's no
like roof it's just drywall beams and
then between it is just drywall you can
fall through it
so she stepped on the drywall and just
went right through the roof
oh my god i thought that this was like
an apartment building so
i thought it was like someone she didn't
know
that's that would be great yeah
that's pretty good i listened to an
interview on this and she's like if you
look at my eyes you can see i'm annoyed
because i hear my mom making noise
upstairs
you know what the screenshot's just got
to be that foot i feel like yeah
yeah i like how the foot just stays
stays there too yeah
yeah it looks like she's comfortable
she's she's
she doesn't struggle at all she's just
chill she's totally content
yeah she's like i'm just gonna chill
here for a bit it's like oh that
happened again
yeah the foot
where does the foot belong
okay well let's let's compare it to what
we know what we know so far
it's not as good as bees these bees
maybe it is maybe it's b
it's a solid yeah i was going to say i
feel like it's at least c tier
i think it's a b actually because
there's some injury
there's some mystery
i'd say a if i'm if i'm being honest
really what's your reasoning for a out
of the shock value in it
maybe it's pretty incredible she caught
it on camera too
yeah definitely shock value let's hold
on before we
make this final judgment is it the kind
of shock value to give you a youtube
strike
that's a good question we'll find out
hold on let's rewatch this one
because before we put it alongside this
great
we need to really carefully consider
what we're
did doing see the comment she pushed the
air too hard
oh i didn't even realize that she was
pushing
oh man oh my god i think she's probably
still falling
yeah no this is more funny i don't know
why
i hope she's okay it sounds maybe it's
just
can you click on their account and see
if that's this girl so we can know if
she's still alive
it looks like this belonged to her oh
there's just a fail page with the
huh oh [ __ ]
oh so it's surprised she's dead she's
definitely dead
her family privateed her account
she's dead unfortunately
you know it might be the same lady she
just hit the roof
you know that's her leg
yeah i i gotta disagree with you zach
yeah it's not on the same level i could
put it in the middle
but i don't know if the hell she's
falling in between the tears
i'd like to imagine the woman falling
through the ceiling and the girl
falling into the abyss is like a
sequence like that's where she ended up
right yeah
yeah it's this if it's the same person
then it's gotta be a
i just like the image of the foot there
well here we go i think we i think we've
i think we've done it
this is important work i feel like it's
a good looking distribution
yeah yeah that's a that is you know it's
better than
yeah because sometimes we do these and
it gets really clustered around a few
tears but we've we got a nice spread
yeah [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this girl yeah i guess if there's
one thing that we've learned from this
let's [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] this guy and [ __ ] these people
not really they just doing a goof but
they're f just because it sucked
yeah i kind of feel like [ __ ] all of
them except the girl that fell
uh this girl who we wish well and hope
she's well and survived yeah
i hope she's well yeah pretty much the
opposite for everyone else
i think everyone else was hurt badly
yeah
i wish what happened to her happened to
everyone else
okay danny i feel like we've covered a
lot of ground
we've done a lot of important work
together yeah i feel like we've changed
lives today
i'm pretty happy about it we've changed
lives not as much as the
girl with the screwdriver but we've
tried our best
no yeah the rest of my life i'll be
trying to live up to her probably
god i wish i wish i had more like that i
feel like that is a true s tear
yes it is just but that's why it's so
it's so rare
you know you know i want more like that
it's on a different level for sure
anything else yeah i'm just thinking is
there anything else
i was just thinking about her dad still
yeah i was like thinking about that man
nice car too i wonder what they do for a
living i wonder if it affected their
business
[ __ ] i'm just thinking about her dad man
he was so proud he seems cool
he's kind of cool in a way so little and
get your dad
involved and be proud still is pretty
epic
i think he is kind of a cool dad alert
because like he's willing he's like look
it's your thing
i trust you i don't know yeah
boomer as [ __ ] though
yeah so what do we think uh
uh you you've been to
pier one uh what other home uh tchotchke
uh stores do you like uh what
i don't know well i've been kind of into
like house plants lately so i got those
two house plants so
i've been going to like lowe's to get
some plants lowe's is good
i like lows you never know what you'll
find there
yeah they've got a pretty good garden
section too
i love going there before the holidays
and getting all the weird like uh
inflatable lit characters
lowe's has the best holiday
[ __ ] yeah straight you guys seen
there's halloween decorations out now
we just went to oh it's already out
yesterday they've already got
halloween decorations done we haven't
left our house since like february i'm
so depressed i'm not even
i'm not even saying that to be funny i
haven't left my house
since this whole thing started and i'm
just so [ __ ] bitterly depressed
do you go outside for like walks or
anything yeah yes i wouldn't do that
okay
that's good sometimes i go for a drive
but the thought of going into lowe's
no way yeah it is kind of overwhelming
so a lot of people when you go there
uh no i feel like i usually go at
non-peak hours also because i can go
during the day since i don't have like a
nine to five or anything
um but yeah no i mean i live in the
suburbs it's not like
la i feel like everything's pretty
crowded but
well danny thank you for coming on it
was really fun
yeah absolutely thank you guys for
having me and keep slamming on youtube
i'm a fan i'm going to keep watching and
i think it's great what you're doing
you're making
wholesome beautiful content on youtube
which i like to see honestly i'm a toxic
[ __ ] and i appreciate people who can
succeed who aren't toxic [ __ ] no i
don't think that's true
i think that one of the reasons that
like drew and i started doing commentary
is because
of like people like you i like
when you i guess i've heard you say
before that like people on
doing commentary are generally pretty
toxic but you were like the only
one of the only like commentary people
that i watched before i started doing
commentary
so you were like the only reference i
had besides like drew for what
commentary is so
that's nice i appreciate you saying that
yeah sure
definitely more toxic than you though
you're a sweetheart you do like lacroix
tearless and [ __ ] yeah
cheers to that well thanks man i wish
you well
lots of continued success thank you for
coming on i had a lot of fun
and god bless you yeah for sure man
thanks guys
thank you dude